this is crazy look at the police
everywhere and everything guys nervous
I'm terrified like I'm not in a good
mood right now
Mike the situation in has been serving a
prison sentence for tax evasion now is
Jersey Shore cast is ready for his
release we're gonna eat he's gonna want
fast food he's gonna want to go to I
can't believe it's actually here today
today's the day hope for the best
prepare for the worst the whole process
will be documented on jersey shore
family vacation it returns July 11th my
heart is racing right now but at the end
of the day needs a whole layette high
with grace and class for myself and my
family and the group says the situation
is making the best of his current
situation yep so reddit right now I
don't know we're gonna do a rave he's
totally fed up the moment he gets back
yeah a couple days and now one day one
bit you do there's a keto gluey don't I
feel like he wants to go in for like a
solid year oh yeah yeah
I'm like ready to like like crying Mike
is seemingly looking forward to his
future yes like the good kids more than
I mean coming in